welcome to this video playing at the
National master cassoulet from from
France and am Jonathan do her soul okay
okay so um yeah the fantasy variation of
the cow calm I had between b6 was my
recommendation when I produce this video
series for as you see this is some
possible line normally white takes with
the night because well this is I think
thought to be okay Ferb like but it's
not not totally clear or easy or
anything this is just a very very
complicated line okay he took Bishop c5
there's always night if for but his
queen before so that's not an issue so
maybe I just do that right a for that
screen before okay he allows me to him
give this check and get his King to e2
is this very often it's not a big
problem funny enough maybe just the
development I mean night a for this
Bishop f2 now which is just quite strong
leading to made I think so he cannot do
that I just try to develop and try to
prove that this is not a great structure
but maybe yeah maybe after move like
that I have this problem with them with
94
okay so that if I was so annoying
because it makes it more difficult for
me to to prevent them from castling and
this is really a key of plex play and 97
yeah maybe this night a fork we near
five checks III and then retreat the
bishop but I don't have a good square to
retreat to mm okay yeah probably i did
something wrong here this looks like a
looks quite okay for white with Queenie
and with 94 okay didn't play that
interesting enough no night a4 is not
possible because of Queen 85 or let's
say it's not leading to anything
interesting I didn't expect that at all
ok so I'll take that it shouldn't be too
bad Queen H 596 there's no problem night
a for Queen 85 is also quite nice okay
so why can take on be too what is Sir
what is he playing after cool after that
actually queen bee to
takes on if I ever take a one and then
there is no move for the King really and
clicking the two and give up h1 but I
don't really believe that I can Castle
long in one move I mean I don't see the
big idea now a 1 hang see three eggs
okay I is going for this sacrifice but
well king d 2 is the only move to to try
to justify that and I don't think it
should work okay take here and now well
queen age five but I have 96 check i
have 96 and i don't really see it
working or g6 even maybe g6 g6 Queen g5
if i take i think i can just plain a g6
come on let's not make a big fuss out of
that if it takes g7 i also have Queen
takes g2 with a check so I should really
be okay I mean and this is a very
conservative expression probably yeah
I'm just winning him yeah okay Bishop g7
if it does not take g7 it's it's really
completely pointless right okay I'm
taking now here jack yeah but yeah he
even has to interpose okay a question is
what about long castles Bishop takes h8
this is this one hanging okay
okay what does the easiest way to play
him maybe start with this check c3 long
castles and then I'm threatening night
f4 which is pretty strong yeah I need to
be a bit quick quick about it I don't
think that a king move doesn't this help
in any way kien d1 is a straight check
may drop King see one I play okay now
I'm long castles and Bishop age eight
there is night f form but taking the
Queen and threatening rocket III and the
same thing is happening he does not have
a check and rook takes d3 is really
strong it's also Queen takes e2 if he
moves the Queen to ask where does not
protect you too why if there is no move
really it should be a total devastation
yeah minus 21 those kind of variations
are always funny just one or two apply a
short of a meeting we made to find um I
think that white was probably doing very
well here because I did something wrong
probably not sure maybe Bishop c5 I
thought this was was good really it
didn't he didn't go for that the problem
is this is completely useless no my
queen has no square to protect the
bishop chain this was my idea c3 now
he's threatening before winning so I
need to move it probably here and then
let's say before Queen here be sure to
find those pieces are not are not
particularly well placed I mean I'm not
lost or anything but it's it's not
looking too great I mean this is a bit
of a traffic jam maybe I should even
a bishop f8 as weird as it looks to to
have have this something like that night
to g6 computers as usual quite merciless
Bishop c4 a very nice yeah I cannot take
obviously is 60 SI to totally killing
and I must play here another computer
gives this as Ackley edge first side it
does not look super clear to me but
there is maybe night before as well yeah
well you can fight in this type of
positional position but it's not not
really fun yeah I probably screwed up
somehow in the opening not quite sure
how but around here I like my position
really I've got an active put active
pieces i can cancel long he cannot
Castle short and this pressure on b2 is
really annoying he basically ignored it
to the pressure with Bishop f4 but its
wonders in the computer already gives me
a winning advantage here it does not
find anything and here interestingly
enough short castles with the idea to
enter on f2 yeah it's very nice for
black no doubt about it alright thanks
for watching